[Musique]
eh ouais
je
m
ana
bonjour et bienvenue dans mode d'emploi
le magazine qui vous donne les clés pour
construire votre projet professionnel
des robots ou des ouvriers connectez
vous en voyez de plus en plus les
technologies de demain vous intéresse
petit retour en arrière pour comprendre
ce qu est l industrie du futur le monde
industriel a connu bon nombre de
révolutions de l'arrivée du charbon à la
machine à vapeur de l'électricité aux
automates ou encore au robot aujourd'hui
une nouvelle ère se profile celle où l'
usine temps à fusionner avec internet
cette aire 4.0 repose sur l'intégration
du numérique et la mise en réseau des
outils et postes de travail dans
l'ensemble de la chaîne de production
mais comment être paré à ces changements
mode d'emploi vous donne les réponses
au sommaire de ce magazine nous irons à
la rencontre d'un lycéen pour comprendre
ce qui suscite sa vocation au métier
bien connu et plein d'avenir celui
d'électrotechnicien et parce qu'il est
grand temps d'arrêter d' apprendre aux
étudiants à penser comme des machines
le cf fille de montigny le bretonneux
écoles connecté au futur de l'industrie
développe le sens éthique de ces
étudiants ainsi que leur capacité à se
réinventer rencontrons enfin
d'entreprises avaient now spécialiste de
la fabrication additive qui accompagne
les entreprises dans leur transition
industrielle et ce tout au long de la
chaîne de production
mais avant de commencer toute carrière
il est important de déterminer son
projet professionnel savoir quoi faire
comment y arriver sami nous dévoile le
sien dans la famille mille voix de
retrouver la famille où il voit à chacun
son métier avec l'artisanat
amoureux à votre ami c'est quoi la plus
grande invention de tous les temps non
le foot je plaisante je dirais
l'électricité parce que sans électricité
a rien qui marche assez vrai monsieur
foot non plus du coup je me disais si je
deviens électrotechnicien j'aurai
toujours du boulot
ah c'est vrai que footballeur on n'en
vit pas tous bons électrotechnicien donc
était sûr de toi certain talent contact
avec la clientèle
tu passes de chantier en chantier
durerait par installer un appareil non
mais ça a l'air cool
en fait tu as eu le coup de foudre pour
ce métier ou coup de foudre
électrotechnicien tes traits enfantins
enfin oui parce que pour moi la plus
grande avance une clope ça l'humour un
maintien coûte j'ai vraiment un doute un
oui bah ça va
chacun son truc monsieur l'électro
techniciens avec choisir l'artisanat
pour les faire depuis janvier 2007
l'ifa de leur joie et le centre des
formations industrielles d'orly
s'allient pour devenir l'école connecté
au futur de l'industrie direction
montigny le bretonneux à la découverte
de ses talents 4.0
ici nous sommes aux séries fille de
montigny anciennement appelée ifa de
leur joie qui forment 500 étudiants
parents du ceap et au master 2 aux
métiers de l'électronique
l'électrotechnique mais aussi de
l'informatique et de la robotique
cet institut de formation par alternance
qui appartient au réseau des écoles de
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
car ile de france développe des
relations privilégiées avec plus de 500
entreprises
on a des apprentis dans des groupes
comme al khums thales comme louis comme
renoue comme valeo notamment
et puis des entreprises qui peuvent être
un peu plus intermédiaire en tout cas
avec avec un nombre de salariés
inférieur à 50 personnes
c'est une composante intéressante et qui
peut correspondre au sia des
personnalités je pense que le choix
d'une entreprise et un double choix
l'entreprise choisissant collaborateurs
c'est mieux encore quand le
collaborateur choisi aussi son
entreprise et devant le renouvellement
continu des technologiques
l'enseignement académique devient une
nécessité dans sa pédagogie
christian-dumas mise sur trois facultés
comprendre analyser synthétiser
l'ensemble de ce socle là qu'il
développe aussi en entreprise pendant
leurs deux ou trois ans d'apprentissage
dans leur permettre d'être adaptable
pour une poursuite vers les innovations
c'est donc une méthodologie qu'il faut
retenir et non pas un savoir faire
pratique et ça c'est quelque chose que
l'on peut faire dans un établissement
comme le cfj parce qu'on n'a pas des
groupes très important et puisqu'on a
aussi un personnel encadrant très
motivés après trois semaines en mode
projet journée particulière pour
stéphane monaco qui présente ce core ppi
en soutenance j'ai choisi de réaliser
une araignée robotique et radio
commandée par téléphones tablettes et
autres appareils connectés donc
programmé quelque chose qui va avoir une
finalité dans le monde physique le
principe du robot c'est vrai que c'est
assez intéressant j'ai fait donc de la
conception 3d pour les différents modes
ensuite il ya énormément d'électronique
pour tout ce qui est connectique savoir
comment on va câblée tous les composants
entre et il y a de la programmation pour
venir lui apprendre quels sont les
mouvements élémentaires et après on a
une puce ici qui est une puce bluetooth
qui va permettre de le piloter
c'est par une tablette ou un téléphone
des spécialités interconnectés au
service d'un tout mais qui composeront
également l'industrie du futur surnommé
dr robot sur sa chaîne youtube robot
minute sylvain bourelly popularise avec
passion son savoir ça fait longtemps que
je veux faire le robotique si jamais je
veux qu'un jour je puisse arriver à
travailler là dedans
bah faut que ce soit connu et donc c'est
là qu'il faut que je fasse connaître aux
autres en tant que geek on a bien
regardé un peu fou à tout ce qui existe
et tout savoir tout connaître
ça va être à nous deux quand on va
sortir de la promo de créer notre boîte
probablement et si je veux devenir le
nouveau microsoft il faut se lancer
maintenant avec un taux de réussite aux
examens en moyenne de 83 % et un taux
d'insertion professionnelle de 78% dans
les six mois à l'issue de leur cursus
le cf y est résolument l'école de
référence connecté au futur de
l'industrie
on estime que 75 % des emplois qui
existeront dans 15 ans n'existe pas
encore mais alors comment préparer les
entreprises à accueillir ces nouveaux
profils avait now c'est le moteur de
l'intégration de ces nouvelles
technologies dans l'ensemble de la
chaîne de production
regardez plutôt
[Musique]
après avoir fait ses premiers pas en
2002 au sein de la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul le groupe avait
now
c'est désormais 12 agences 130
collaborateurs de 3000 clients pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 23 millions
d'euros
cette société qui accompagne les
industriels dans leurs projets
d'innovation a su conserver l'âme de
cette équipe
l'esprit start up pour moi il se définit
avec un seul mot c'est l'agilité c'est
la capacité à faire rapidement évoluer
son business model pour s'adapter au
mieux à ses besoins ses clients sa
production
donc on accompagne les clients sur toute
cette chaîne numérique toujours en
croissance
vingt postes d'ingénieurs et techniciens
sont à pourvoir ces douze prochains mois
dans les domaines de la conception et la
fabrication 3d trouver des
collaborateurs qu'on dise ou 15 ans
d'expérience en impression 3d ça
n'existe pas donc on embauche et on va
former en interne les personnes qui
savent répondre à ses besoins
à la suite un bac pro en dessin
industriel la soif d'apprendre de nature
d'auteur s'est fait remarquer chez avait
now je suis comme arranger une
conception pour qu'à fonctionne le mieux
possible que ce soit le plus efficace
en fait j'ai plusieurs versions de
solidor que sur mon poste pour pouvoir
répondre aux questions et surtout se met
à la place du client
quand j'ai commencé c'était un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'effectivement j'avais
pas de pas d'expérience pour
l'entreprise de ma forme et solidworks
m'a formé et après je me suis formé tout
seul en apprenant de des clients
technologie phare du groupe
l'impression 3d permet de réaliser de
nombreux types de pièces avec une large
variété de matériaux combinables la
fabrication additive repousse les
limites de votre créativité en tant que
concepteur
quand on est ingénieur on a un rôle qui
est de concevoir un produit qui aura une
fonction là où on va avoir un vrai gain
sur la fabrication additive c'est
vraiment sur des choses très complexe en
terme de géométrie et justement qu'on
aura optimisé en amont au niveau de la
conception pour remplir une fonction
très précise avec une forme très
complexe la pièce qui auraient pu être
fabriqués de façon traditionnelle en
plein relativement simple en terme de
géométrie par contre comme on est dans
le métier aéro on a une problématique de
réduction du poids
on a des outils de simulation est ce
qu'on appelle d'optimisation de
topologie où on va optimiser la
géométrie pour garder la même résistance
mais gagnant poids participer aux
sessions de recrutement chez ab now
c'est aussi bénéficier d'une cooptation
au sein de son réseau d'industriels car
sa valeur ajoutée convient tant des
technologies innovantes que des
ressources humaines que le groupe mette
à disposition
en un mot abena au propose non pas un
modèle unique de solutions mais
l'intégration de solutions plurielle et
évolutive à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'industrie c'est plus de 620
établissements ce secteur représente 25
mille emplois soit près de 20% des
emplois du territoire sur la région ile
de france ses 460 mille emplois et 44600
établissements dans l'industrie et les
services à l'industrie
voilà l'industrie du futur est en marche
et promet d'être encore davantage
pourvoyeuse d'emplois venez découvrir
ces opportunités lors du salon de
l'industrie du 20 au 26 mars prochain
vous êtes étudiant
sachez également que l'agglomération
organise aussi des visites d'entreprises
du 16 au 24 mars
ainsi des entreprises comme skylab valeo
la sncf lui merck vous ouvriront grand
leurs portes
retrouvez toutes les informations
pratiques sur le site de saint porto
novo ça y est vous avez toutes les clés
en main retrouvez le second épisode de
mode d'emploi le 30 mars prochain il
sera cette fois ci consacré à
l'apprentissage
en attendant portez vous bien
[Musique]